[Music]
well as we know formula one has been
here before 40 years ago the series held
a race in the old parking lot at
caesar's palace where the forum shops
now sit as john langler reports while
organizers today have a swell of support
in the early 80s the event was resisted
from day one every event that we do at
caesars palace bill weinberger in 1981
auto races is an excuse to have a party
bill weinberger in 2022 he was like
who cares
weinberger led marketing for caesar's
palace in the early 80s he was also
president of the grand prix the event
was a tough sell we had many false
starts and
lots of stop and go going on there was
little support from clark county the
state or other strip properties but he
and others were determined to make the
race happen we drew the racetrack on the
back of a placemat at caesar's palace f1
finally arrived in 1981 cab drivers
drove around the parking lot track to
break in the asphalt it was a spectacle
weinberger says most of las vegas though
was uninterested as a casino event it
was a bust we spent a lot of money and
we did not get the return in the casino
that we were hoping to get
now the worldwide circus of f1 is coming
back a race on the strip at night is a
fabulous idea this time there seems to
be support across the board but
weinberger is apprehensive the race can
happen at all it'll be very exciting
whether they can get it on because there
are a lot of the same logistical
problems exist today that existed when
we tried how do you protect the fans how
do you protect the drivers how can you
get the strip fit for race cars not just
street cars they're questions weinberger
hopes can be answered there are some
real safety concerns that can can all be
solved typically with money if you throw
enough money at it somehow you'll figure
it out john langler live local now